like I didn't know that I thought he was  white from Tirana they got to get busy  here Alexander versus Alexander who's  buzzing at the end of the regular season  when Blake Thompson comes back some of  the changes there this year guilt as  Alexander would be and one reads Dallas  down by a point  reporting to go and back quickly the  other head shave gilja's Alexander  always boards on they never just  actually commit to getting into shape  and goods at Alexander's been working on  that three ball stolen State holds on  and wins is Gilda's Alexander in this  series has been just incredible shooting  from the field  56% the Clippers quickly score look at  Jason Kidd are you kidding me  look at Magic Johnson unless I go on oh  sweet move countess Alexander where the  Duke and it's back to floor he's got 21  that deserves the play and deserved it  from day one little fake move